When Markowitz added to the game was
this consideration of variance and
co-variance between individual stocks.
And the recognition
that you want to blend
those together that
have anti-correlation.
So you can have a much lower
risk portfolio if you combine
assets that are anti-correlated.
Or anti-varianced.
[LAUGH] If that is a word.
Because when one moves up,
the other moves down.
They cancel each other out.
And you have much less volatility.
Now of course you want, overall,
all these assets to in
general move up together.
So often what we are looking for is
anti-correlation in the short term and
positive correlation in a longer term.
But out of this work grew
a number of algorithms,
one of the key ones being
mean variance optimization.
Which is a way of taking a potential
set of assets and figuring out how they
should be blended together by looking at
their co-variance among other things.
So let's consider this group of assets
here and how we might combine them or
allocate funds to them to
provide a good portfolio.
One thing I didn't point out
before that I want to mention now.
Is it generally the higher
return stocks or assets,
whatever they might be tend
to also be the highest risk.
So as we roll down the risk we
tend to also look at lower return.
Now again, how do we combine
these into a good portfolio?
Here's what goes in to
a mean variance optimizer.
These are the factors that it considers.
So for each stock you have to
provide an expected return.
In other words,
what do we think in the future it's
going to provide in terms of return.
You also provide volatility and
covariance.
Volatility is simply historically
how volatile has each
one of these assets been.
Covariance is a matrix which
shows between each asset and
every other asset, what is
the correlation of daily returns.
So it takes all of these into
account when it is searching for
the right waiting for
each of these stocks in a portfolio.
So the last and
perhaps one of the most important
inputs to this is the target return.
We can target a return anywhere
from the max return asset
to the min return asset.
And then anything else between those, of
course, we can accomplish by blending.
So let's suppose this is
the level of our target return.
So I'll just put a dotted line here so
we can mark that for later.
So the output of an optimizer is
a set of weights, one weight for
each asset,
that provides the target return.
But minimizes risk, so in the end we're
looking for a portfolio that's out here.
In other words it's got risk that's even
lower than any of the individual assets.
But it meets the target return.
And this is possible because
we consider covariance.
We're only looking at individual risk
we wouldn't be able to find the right
blend that would bring us out here.
Now that's it for optimization and
the insights from Markowitz.
But there's one more thing to look at
with regards to optimizers that I'm
going to show you next.